hello everyone and welcome to another
beautiful game from the semi-finals of
the ftx crypto cup the knockouts young
versus levon arun uh interestingly uh
about this match it's a four game match
of course four game rapid match uh uh
all the games where levon had the white
pieces ended in a draw but the game that
we've shown where levon played the
queen's gambit accepted uh ended by
lavon uh winning that hard fought end
game uh and here duda has one last
chance a chance this is the fourth game
he again has the white pieces and lavone
again employs the uh queen's gambit
accepted
which is uh fascinating uh as uh if you
guys remember capoblanca i even
mentioned that the queen's gambit is not
really a gambit and you don't want to
accept that pawn it's extremely
dangerous to accept that pawn uh but
that's exactly what levon does and he
does it against uh uh a world
championship candidate member uh young
shisht of duda so that's really really
awesome and this game is just uh
incredible the the first game we've
shown in the line uh
featured that very early queen trade and
it was a hard fought end game but here
there are no queen traits and there are
no end games so you guys will enjoy this
one a lot so again uh like in game two
duda opens with the d4 we have d5 uh
pawn to c4 uh sorry about that uh and uh
levon again accepts the gambit d
captures on c4 we have e4 uh e5
everything the same like in game two
knight to f3 and the bishop to b4 with
check we mentioned that e captures on
the e4 is by far the more popular option
but levon has his own ideas and here
knight to c3 so duda no longer wants to
play bishop to d2 go for uh very early
trades and trade the queen early on uh
instead knight to c3 we have e captures
on d4 and now knight captures on d4 we
have knight to d7 by 11
and bishop captures on c4 knight g2f6
and both players castle so castles
castles and now duda plays knight d to
e2 keeping everything on the board uh
and saying that um
he he wants to have as much stuff on the
board as possible to somehow allow him
to to actually win the game
and of course it is as of move 9 that we
have a completely new game
now we have knight to the e5 by lavon
attacking the bishop and offering a
queen trade and duda says all right i
can't really prevent the queen trade so
at least bishop to b3 at least i'm going
to get my rook to d1 after you trade
queens but elevon says nope you trade
queens if you want to trade queens i
want to get my rook to d8 if you decide
to trade so h3 of course they are
ignoring each other queen to e7 now
levon no longer has the queen trade uh
on the table and rook is coming to d8 we
have pawn to f4 kicking away the knight
which of course is possible as the g4
and c4 square are not available so the
knight usually has to go back but here
levon throws a nice in between rook to
d8 and this is where things get
incredibly interesting as this is the
position from the thumbnail here there
is basically only one good option for
duda and that is to give up the queen
it's it's odd
but even though this is the absolute
best move for duda it's not enough
because duda has to win this game and if
he ex if he captures the rook although
it looks fancy and spectacular and what
not it it's basically a force draw
because after queen and the eighth and
queen captures and he captures uh f
captures on e5 okay now the knight
cannot move um because the f7 pawn falls
but there's really nothing better you
can give one check let's say bishop to
c5 checking to h1 and now play knight to
g4 uh and now duda will not be able to
capture the knight because of this
checkmate as the bishop covers the g1
square so you're gonna go after the f7
pawn rook captures an f7 now threatening
all sorts of nasty discoveries uh king
h8 only good move for levon would be
here and now let's say bishop to f4 uh
and now we basically get a rep at a
repetition i to f2 with check you do not
want to go to g1
uh so you're gonna play keying to h2
knight to g for check again you cannot
capture because of this checkmate and we
would most likely see a repetition if uh
dude actually went for the for the queen
traitor or rather a queen sacrifice with
queen capture 78 so although it looks
spectacular and i
i'm sure that duda wanted to play this
it's just that he can't even continue to
play the game that's the problem and
that's why you cannot um go for this so
he played queen to c2 queen to e1 was
another uh good option allowing knight
to d3 but um
after queen to c2 it just all falls
apart for dude bishop the c5 with check
king the h1 now knights the d3 uh going
after that f2 square and you know that
the knight is also coming to g4 so e5
challenging the knight here but still
knights to g4 again the knight cannot be
captured because of the same checkmate
the bishop covers the g1 square so after
knight to g4 we have knight to e4
but now comes a move that
completely destroys duda uh
interestingly there is only one winning
move for levon here and he has to be
very very precise but that's where you
guys come in feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the winning
move for levon
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on bringing our good
friend the light square bishop into the
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it's bishop to f5 the
only winning move and now uh duda is uh
basically moveless if that's even a word
uh
this is this is a huge problem uh for
example uh just to give you an idea
let's say you play knight captures and
c5 knight f2 check picks up the queen so
uh
you can't play that what can you play uh
well duda finds the only good move in
the position and that is knight due to
g3
putting pressure on the bishop here but
now we just start checking on the f2
square as that's what this position is
all about so knight d2 f2 with check uh
and now what do you do if you capture
with the rook
it does seem like it's possible but the
other knight recaptures and now after
king to h2 we just go bishop captures an
e4 and after knight captures we're going
to play knight captures queen captures
and
you can play this but you're down the
exchange and there's nothing really to
show for here uh it's a it's a good try
but against levon duda decides that
there's no point in playing this that
the two rooks once they uh are activated
and it's very easy to activate them for
example you can play rook d4 the other
row comes to d8 and already it's very
hard to find moves for white so instead
to do that tri is the only thing that's
left and that is to give up the queen
knight captures on f2 and levon happily
accepts this we have bishop captures on
c2 knight captures on g4 and now bishop
captures on b3 uh a characters on b3 and
now rook to d3 activating the rook with
tempo attacking the knights of knights
the e4 and now even f5
uh trying to finish the game in great
style uh if uh for example e captures an
f6 alpha song then
the knight is hanging but also there are
ideas like rook captures and h3 queen
captures here uh just completely uh
destroying white so here knight captures
and c5 is played queen captures on c5
and now knight to f2 attacking the rook
here rook to d5 and now rook to a4 dude
are still fighting but um yeah there's
some the the difference in material is
too great rook eight to the eighth rook
the c4 attacks the queen now queen b5
pinning this rook uh and he was in this
position on move 25 that young shirt of
duda resigned in the game as there is
nothing more to be done here uh he's i
mean he he does have a bishop at night
for a queen but his position is uh
there's really nothing to to even try
it's really a hopeless position and um
well yeah he just doesn't feel like
continuing the game so what's uh
incredible here is that the levon
employed the queen's gambit accepted won
that hard-fought game uh in game two
that uh was very very hard to win uh but
then in game two where duda tried
something else he kept the queens on the
board but uh uh uh when it came to this
position where uh basically the uh uh
sorry not this position this position
we're basically the only good way to
continue the game is queen capture 78
duda could not go for it because he's
already losing the the match and he has
to
uh you know retain winning chances and
by going for the strongest move uh he he
could not do that so yeah very
interesting uh
it's basically something
if you were analyzing this game as a
game in itself and not as a part of the
match then maybe you wouldn't it would
be hard to understand to do this choice
not to play queen capture 78 uh because
you can be sure that this is the first
move that duda thought of when
uh pondering on the position uh but as
it is a part of the match you do they
had to play something else in order you
know uh in order to try and prolong this
game to maybe win the match but it
wasn't possible so that's why sometimes
when uh we analyze the games that are a
part of a rapid match or or four game
match or you know for a four game blitz
match it doesn't really matter
the games will not be as precise and as
uh
the moves will not be as strong as you
would expect in a classical game even
though the players see the moves and
they know that they should play the
moves so it's weird but uh it's
something that you know uh it is now
just the way it is uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it levon uh
defeats the young shisht of duda a world
champion championship candidate and in
the other match of wei yi versus rihard
rapport uh another candidate has fallen
as a way ye pretty much annihilated
richard rapport first game ended in a
draw then we won the the next two games
uh so he won with black and with white
and now we will have levon versus wei yi
in the finals uh of the uh of the ftx
road to miami knockout so which is uh
really really incredible uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it uh
do study the queen's gamut accepted as
you never know when you might uh have to
face it or when you might uh you know
surprise your your opponent with it uh i
would like to thank uh hi alon uh paul
dindio francis air baba nugmanov and
margo ping for contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals
until it finishes uh so thank all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day